[موسيقى]
درجات الحرارة المرتفعة بالإضافة إلى الرطوبة المرتفعة ، وهو
مزيج يحتمل أن يكون خطيرًا من
الواضح أن الصيف هو موسم
الحرارة الطارئة ، وتتراوح أمراض الحرارة من معتدلة
إلى شديدة ، وأكثرها شيوعًا هي الطفح الحراري
حيث يصبح جلدك متهيجًا بسبب
تشنجات الحرارة الحمراء ، وتشنجات مؤلمة في
عضلاتك ، والإرهاق الناتج عن الحرارة.
يتميز بالتعرق الشديد
وسرعة النبض الضعيف في التنفس السريع
وضربة الشمس التي يمكن أن
تهدد الحياة وذلك عندما
يفقد الجسم القدرة على تنظيم
أعراض الحرارة لضربة الشمس ، بما في ذلك
النبض القوي السريع والدوخة والإغماء أو
فقدان الوعي.
وتغيير الحالة العقلية والغثيان والجلد الأحمر الجاف
الساخن إذا كان الشخص يعاني من هذه الأعراض ،
فاتصل برقم 911 على الفور لا تنتظر لمساعدته ،
يقول الدكتور توماس ووتر مع
كليفلاند كلينك ، إن مقدار الضرر
الذي تعرفه يمكن أن يكون أسوأ كلما
زاد ارتفاع درجة حرارة الشخص.  تريد أن
تبدأ في تبريد شخص ما بمجرد
أن تعرف أن هناك
مشكلة بضربة حرارة تغطيتها بالوات  من أجل
السماح لذلك بالتبخر وتبديد
الحرارة ولكن أيضًا كمادات الثلج جيدة ، يمكنك
وضعها على الفخذ والإبطين ،
تلك الأنواع من المناطق للمساعدة في تبريد شخص ما
إذا كنت ستخرج في درجات حرارة عالية ،
خذ فترات راحة متكررة وشرب
الماء كل  15 دقيقة حتى لو
لم تكن عطشانًا ، ارتدي قبعة وملابس فضفاضة
وخفيفة الوزن وخفيفة الوزن وتجنب
الكحول والكافيين وتقليل
شدة عبء العمل أو التمرين
لدقيقة صحية أحتاجها